come on
Texican come on how are you can't get a
cab I wonder why the London cab drivers
what does he done to upset you and I
think they are perhaps now the most
frustrating drivers on the planet they
give you the big one and the little one
folded on your bike son no line mate
Gordon you won this cab back off so a
couple years ago I upset these guys on
telly and ever since that night that I
choose to pick me up some here to make
amends ones in trouble he can't cook to
save his life I just hope he's in a good
mood because normally there are
miserable [ __ ] I've always relied on my
wife in ten years so that when I get in
from work on one of them there'd be a
nice dinner on the table I've never been
asked to take that in an ad to cook I've
always hated dinner I'm not worried
about where it came from whatever they
think is a sandwich I'll hop cross
farmer sonic can cook that bacon then
that the sausage you could not let a
proper big dinner I set out with my wife
and then I've got the two kids and I'm
forever getting takeaways whenever I've
got um they're not eating healthy food
cool what a [ __ ]
how old are the kids Alfie's nine any
beers nearly seven uh huh so born ago
yep
and you've never cooked them never you
can't even do beans on toast well but I
can do beans on toast I'm one about a
nice lunch for a Mustang because
wherever you do those kids now is a
reflection of you is there horsies we
start working overhead of us yeah yeah
that's like every time we get to cap the
meters always on yes huh no wonder you
guys are so rich on a few good summer
it's gonna take a lot to get this light
and let out the dark ages and
comfortable in the kitchen look over the
dish that's got nine or ten uses start
with a shepherd's pie lovely but the
most important thing about that is the
mince I'm making a really nice savoury
mince lovely coz on the back of that
once it's been used for a shepherd's pie
they can just evolve it spaghetti okay
roll on yeah then you've got Yola Sonia
carried mince with some seasoning dad so
on the stove um though yeah I've got
this what I might say no no at this exam
Johnny I am known all that you're making
on each other you're making me nervous
turn the [ __ ] stove on I'll kill the
onions yeah you pull the carrots let the
knife do the work look just lift the
knife up and just push the carrots down
okay all the way through that's it it's
nice and slow nice and slow
oh really voila voila look at this the
only chance on working lagina Ashford
yet so far no no and the hot plate
stands is high so I thought I would
never go to see a little head come in
the hot plate by the garlic drop it nice
and fine last fall in the man give a
good mix flavor
fresh thyme take a little bit like that
yeah I'm alright ride it yeah is a herb
but it is so so nice
mmm not expire at the end like an eddy
no that's nice the mellow right now that
sweaty down add some tomato puree half a
blast red wine and lamb mince [ __ ]
without putting it on the floor Johnny
now I got him on the [ __ ] swag gucci
buckles oh you've got mints on your gold
bar what a beef stock and what's the
source then turn down the heat to simmer
special time with the kids that weekend
yet yeah this give me frozen and that's
a way of sort of just getting organized
yeah oh [ __ ] are they new towel she does
it put down yeah so are they legit can
we stand on the ground then you get done
for suddenly Tolliver making out all
right dodgy character at the long
carries a dodgy in Japan and back on the
stove Johnny please yet will do
and you know what as well go on slowly
feeling more confident ready yeah that
little mash thank you into the delay
Thames almost like icing a cake here so
I spread cheese on top now popping the
elastic helpful a live yeah yeah thanks
man see like missing boom ah Golden's
here hi guys
Knickerbocker glory chairing the bottom
yeah get them involved like that they've
got these memories they go up so you are
I
looking action of the very second and
they get to eat party oh my god
who needs paperweight well you got that
mmm yeah really one crucial question do
you want dad to cook this again guess
well yeah would you think mommy would
think oh god SPECT this is how something
like should be 100 yen but I mean you
can make the effort you're the only
person can do this you know well they're
an age where they're gonna remember
everything
thank you very much and feed on it he's
never had to cook with his life for now
he's got no choice because he's gonna
look after these two kids and you know
that's something loves there has to be
10,000 times better than a [ __ ]
takeaway for your kids
taxi thank you so next I want you to do
is to get the staff on what does this do
the saffron gives it an amazing colour
and gives it a really nice flavor as
well